Iowa is a first state where Democrats
and Republicans get to pick their
favorite presidential candidate why the
Hawkeye State didn't always get to
choose first it happened by accident in
1972 Iowa Democrats were forced to move
their first caucus meeting up to January
because new party regulations required a
certain amount of time between party
events when Iowa politicians realized
that having an early contests meant that
their state got tons of media attention
and an economic boost from the influx of
media campaign workers they wrote Iowa's
first in the nation status into state
law no other state has succeeded in
breaking this tradition some say giving
Iowa first pic makes sense because it's
a small state which forces candidates to
meet voters face to face and get
personal but critics argue that it's not
representative of the rest of the u.s.
so it's wrong to give them such an
outsized role in picking the next
presidential candidate what do you think